you do I just called everybody back
there he look
wonderful I
was I know
right it so like validates my reality I
was driving to work today and I was like
I can't believe I'm going to get to hug
Jason mimoa today like how did how it
was good is it going to
[Applause]
fit it's it's everything in the world by
the way I feel this
muscle like that's very prominent that
back muscle right here speaking of
muscles you like like had a Chris
Hemsworth muscle off recently yeah I did
I did I did yeah it's funny cuz we're
good Buds and uh it's I was actually
going to he has a wonderful company
centerfit and they teach you how to
train and and it's it's I was asking if
he would help me get in shape like why
do you need to know about getting in
shap he's like he's really in shape and
I don't you like I enjoy beer and pasta
a little too much so I'm like I'm a big
fan of like pasta me I mean pasta is my
life and you know what here's the good
news there's a huge scientific study out
right now I saw that isn't that the
coolest happiness that's why we're so
happy I know pasta makes you happier
it's it's literally like neurons brain
it's science don't even question it well
I have a clip actually of you and Chris
doing a back and forth what's up
samworth you had a workout I
didn't it's a lovely padded costume you
got there Jason I could prefer a skin
suit myself night
okay I love you
Aquaman I mean he's
he's he's a dream boat he's wonderful I
love him I love two men just measuring
those muscles he's uh yeah I mean listen
he's got the real deal and mine have I
have to put a suit on to be that big
he's he's pretty big I don't are you
wearing anything right now you're
wearing a skin tight sweater and it
looks like you you look like Aquaman I
watched itasy thank you thank
you you maying me
[Music]
blush